Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
How do people create these beautiful computer
generated images and videos that we see in
Hollywood blockbuster movies?
In the world of light simulation programs,
to obtain a photorealistic image, we create
a digital copy of a scene, add a camera and
a light source, and simulate the paths of
millions of light rays between the camera
and the light sources.
This technique we like to call path tracing
and it may take several minutes to obtain
only one image on a powerful computer.
However, in these simulations, the rays of
light are allowed to bounce off of the surface
of objects.
In reality, many objects are volumes, where
the rays of light can penetrate their surface
and scatter around before exiting or being
absorbed.
Examples include not only rendering amazingly
huge smoke plumes and haze, but all kinds
of translucent objects, like our skin, marble,
wax, and many others.
Such an extended simulation program we call
not path tracing but volumetric path tracing,
and we can create even more beautiful images
with it, however, this comes at a steep price:
if the classical path tracing took several
minutes per image, this addition of complexity
often bumps up the execution time to several
hours.
In order to save time, we have to realize
that not all light paths contribute equally
to our image.
Many of them carry barely any contributions,
and only a tiny tiny fraction of these paths
carry the majority of the information that
we see in these images.
So what if we could create algorithms that
know exactly where to look for these high
value light paths and systematically focus
on them?
This family of techniques we call importance
sampling methods.
These help us finding the regions where light
is concentrated, if you will.
This piece of work is an excellent new way
of doing importance sampling for volumetric
path tracing, and it works by identifying
and focusing on regions that are the most
likely to scatter light.
And, it beats the already existing importance
sampling techniques with ease.
Now, to demonstrate how simple this technique
is, a few years ago, during a discussion with
one of the authors, Marcos Fajado, I told
him that I would implement their method in
real time on the graphical card in a smaller
than four kilobyte program.
So we made a bet.
Four kilobytes is so little, we can store
only a fraction of a second of mp3 music in
it.
Also, this is an empty file generated with
Windows Word.
Apparently, in some software systems, the
definition of "nothing" takes several times
more than 4 kilobytes.
And after a bit of experimentation, I was
quite stunned by the results, because the
final result was less than 2 kilobytes, even
if support for some rudimentary animations
is added.
The whole computer program that executes volumetric
path tracing with this equiangular importance
sampling technique fits on your business card...
twice.
Absolute insanity.
I've put a link discussing some details in
the video description.
Now, don't be fooled by the simplicity of
the presentation here, the heart and soul
of the algorithm that created the rocket launch
scene in Men in Black 3 is the same as this
one.
Due to legal reasons it is not advisable to
show it to you in this video, but this is
fortunately one more excellent reason for
you to have a look at the paper!
As always, the link is available in the video
description.
This is my favorite kind of paper, where there
are remarkably large gains to be had, and
it can be easily added to pretty much any
light simulation program out there.
I often like to say that the value/complexity
ratio is tending towards infinity.
This work is a prime example of that.
By the way, Marcos and his team recently won
a technical Oscar award, not only for this,
but for their decades of hard work on their
Arnold renderer, which is behind many many
Hollywood productions.
I've put a link to their website in the video
description as well, have a look!
Congrats guys!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!